we begin in greece where massive
wildfires have left hundreds of people
homeless
and forced thousands to evacuate the
flames have been fanned by greece's
worst heat wave in more than three
decades
as some smaller blazers are brought
under control residents who had been
forced to flee
are trying to return home many are
asking if authorities could have acted
sooner
our correspondent barbara wessel reports
from athens
irini has been living on this hillside
all her life
and now she refuses to leave the
neighborhood had been evacuated the
night before
but irene has come back slowly and all
on her own
please tell them to throw some water in
my house i want to go in
police and the firefighter are arguing
with the old lady
you must come with us it's too dangerous
they say
but in the end the police wins of course
down the road a group of volunteers is
fighting a heroic battle
they have commandeered an ancient truck
and are trying to save their
neighborhood with one fire hose
a lot of muscle power and desperation
but small fires are constantly
rekindling on the hillside of this
protected nature reserve part of the
green lung of essence
the place is on fire we lost the most
precious piece of essence
we grew up here we're hurting and crying
because of this catastrophe
further up the professionals have moved
in and a small rescue operation gets
underway
one of the volunteers has hurt his leg
climbing up the steep terrain
meanwhile outside help has arrived from
france israel bulgaria
and other european countries here it's a
cypriot firefighters
trying to shoulder the burden
the situation is really difficult it's
tragic we work together and help our
greek colleagues
we face a much worse situation here than
we had expected
where the firefighters came too late
there is total devastation
volunteers are battling on with shovels
to extinguish the stubborn flames
a disaster there burning our country
this was a virgin forest and they burned
it
it's so sad not only is the forest gone
here
the animals are suffering somebody left
this donkey
when fleeing the area neighbors are now
trying to help
this owner left it behind here to die
from the fire
thousands of animals have already died
in these flames
in a few weeks the fires may be gone but
it's going to take
decades for these hills to heal again
dw correspondent barbara vessel filed
that report and she joins us now from
athens
barbara good to see you another night of
battling fires
how are people coping where you are
people are getting increasingly angry
and they are really
battling i mean i've never seen so many
volunteers out whole neighborhoods have
come out
everybody who can carry a hose or a
shovel or a hoe
is trying to climb up on those hillsides
and sort of
extinguish the fires they're really
stubborn because the
the forest floor has burned and there is
so much burnable material there
that it just comes up again and and just
rekindles
all the time as we have seen and it is
really desperate and the more people
fight the more angry and of course the
more sad they get
it is a really difficult situation
overall
it has become a bit better because the
government has doubled the number of
firefighters in the area from 400
to 800 and they have during the day
yesterday made a big difference
they have brought the fires under
control at least so they're not raging
anymore
sort of and jumping into new
neighborhoods
they're keeping the flames in place but
still it's not over yet it's still
ongoing particularly in other parts of
the green main
greek mainland where in one area 70
percent
of the forest and of the whole area has
burned down
people there are in utter despair you
mentioned barbara in your report earlier
that the
aftermath of the wildfires is already
talk of how to rebuild
of course it is i mean the the prime
minister mitsutakis
he has been keen to go on television a
lot trying to send out consoling
messages
telling people he feels muslim and he
also promised yesterday
that he would replant all those forests
around
essence which are really so important
for the
ecological survival of this huge built
up city
but that is a promise easily made and
very difficult to really
implement because how are you these are
decades-old forests
those are indigenous forests replant the
trees it's going to take
20 years at least till something can
grow again plus
people we talked to on those hills said
what will happen in the winter once the
rains come
is that we will have the most horrible
landslides because
all the soil is going to come jump in
you know falling down those hills
so one catastrophe might follow on the
other
barbara thank you very much dw
correspondent barbara vessel in athens
now while parts of greece continue to
burn other parts of southern europe the
mediterranean and russia
are also battling blazes fires in turkey
have claimed at least
eight lives meanwhile hundreds of fires
are burning in kosovo
places in north macedonia have forced
the government to declare a state of
emergency
there and fires in albania have
threatened homes
wildfires in siberia and russia's far
east are still burning
several weeks after they ignited their
dozens of
villages have been evacuated
you